[Musique]
au sommaire de ce numéro
l'invité christophe muniesa directeur
général de la fédération française de
golf et directeur technique national à
quelques mois de la ryder cup
comment se porte le golf en france et
quelles sont les chances de voir un
joueur français
intégrez l'équipe européenne réponse
avec cet ancien joueur du circuit qui
semble l'un des meilleurs connaisseurs
golf en france et dans le monde
le parcours du mois dépaysement pour ce
numéro puisque nous vous proposons un
voyage en catalogne à la découverte du
pga catalonia resort en compagnie de sa
directrice monique à martinez leur dit
gough se développe de plus en plus en
france car heureusement les structures
mêmes l'enseignement s'adapte à ceux qui
ont connu des accidents de ma vie gros
plan sur ce handigolf avec denis éric
délégué handigolf ile-de-france évasion
pour finir avec la magnifique exposition
de photos ce minime parisse réalisé à
l'occasion de la ryder cup par l'éditeur
du magazine farways antoine gaveau
[Musique]
christophe milliers à bonjour bonjour
patrice vous êtes le directeur de la
fédération française de golf
vous êtes aussi le directeur technique
national donc quand même beaucoup de
choses à aborder ray vous parlez un peu
la situation d'une france est peut-être
dû au niveau de la ryder cup évident et
puis un peu de vous si vous permettez
alors commençons par la situation du
golf français
est ce que vous sentez déjà un effet
ryder cup brusque encore qui peut tout
ça va se produire un plus en arrive vers
la compétition et peut-être après des
alors il ya déjà un petit peu
d'effervescence évidemment autour de
l'accueil de la compétition un peu de
curiosité aussi puisque c'est la
première fois que cet événement sera
accueilli en france donc du côté des
médias du côté des partenaires publics
ou des partenaires privés willy a
indéniablement un coup de projecteur sur
l'activité après auprès du grand public
ça va monter en puissance gentiment mais
je crois qu'il ya encore beaucoup de
gens en france qui ne sont pas
totalement informés sur l'axé de
semences que c'est exact et dago gic a
fait un gros travail pédagogique à la
situation du golf en france des clubs
d'aider des joueurs du nombre de joueurs
c'est plutôt positif
oui alors très très clairement il ya une
très forte croissance de la pratique du
golf dans les années 80 90 et
la fédération de golf aujourd'hui c'est
la sixième en termes de nombre de
licenciés c'est pas mal
ah c'est effectivement il ya une très
forte croissance
après c'est vrai qu'au cours des cinq
six dernières années on a plutôt assisté
une stagnation en france à l'échelle
mondiale il ya des fédérations qui était
très très développés comme la fédération
américaine et fération britannique
qu'ont connu un léger recul
principalement pour des raisons
économiques sur l'organisation des clubs
eux-mêmes
nous on a stagné on commence à avoir un
petit pétillement voilà et ça repart du
bon pied
c'est vrai que ça prend du temps c'est
vrai oui ce sont ce que vous évoquez
sont les freins principaux au
développement de la pratique le temps le
coup même si ça s'est beaucoup plus
modiques et ce n'était le cas dans les
années 80 aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup
plus abordable de jouer au golf ce qui
est un facteur de développement
donc le temps le coup et puis aussi
d'une manière qui au plus générale
l'image c'est à dire que c'est le sport
individuel le plus pratiqué au monde
mais en france on a du mal à s'en rendre
compte encore on reste parfois sur des
images relativement date et donc ses
formules de jeu accélérer le plan de
création de cent petites équipes
manquent annoncé la fédération de
manière concomitante avec le projet
d'accueil de la ryder cup
ça a permis aussi de rendre la pratique
plus accessible et ce qui est si c'est
ce qui permet d'attirer de nouveaux
publics plus de jeunes et plus de
féminines aussi on est aujourd'hui un
ratio de 30 70 entre les hommes et les
femmes on n'est pas les suédois 58 la
parité
il ya de la vraie variété mais chez les
britanniques par exemple pour les
américains on est plutôt à 85,15 même
des terres des clubs interdit aux femmes
est exact encore donc ils ont pris du
retard
donc nous on est plutôt pas mal placé
sur ces
facteur là mais indéniablement il ya
encore des efforts à faire les efforts
aussi j'aimerais après une statistique
que j'avais vu c'est aussi les jeunes
par exemple père de famille les gens qui
commencent à la fois dans le travail
leur carrière professionnelle et puis
avoir une famille qui ont un peu moins
de taux si oui on retombe sur cette
problématique de tentes et dans les
allées bien sûr bien sûr dans les
actions de promotion de la fédé on met
justement surtout en avant cette
dimension qui est assez unique par
rapport à la pratique de votre sport
c'est la dimension familiale et rares
sont les sports sur lesquels vous pouvez
jouer le grand père le petit risque donc
c'est vraiment intergénérationnel mixte
donc on met vraiment l'accent sur cette
dimension familiale pour séduire les
parents autant que les enfants
alors évidemment il ya la ryder cup
alors dans tout ça est ce qu'il y aura
un français sélectionnés de la ryder cup
oui alors c'est évidemment une fois une
question à ce sujet auquel on est très
attaché la perspective de l'accueil de
la ryder cup c'est a eu un effet ultra
positif sur la motivation des joueurs
français oui donc sur la filière
sportive en elle-même
ça a vraiment eu un effet d'accélérateur
ça c'est très positif
après pour ce qui est du mode de
sélection sur la compétition c'est un
système avec un calcul de points et le
capitaine thomas ce band qui est danois
il va évidemment s'appuyer de manière
prépondérante sur le système de points
c'est donc le premier classé avant le
1er octobre mais il a la possibilité
aussi de sélectionner des joueurs qu'on
appelle des wild-cards on est comme des
invitations et
les bons résultats notamment d'
alexander levy le fait que comme par
hasard sur certains tournois du european
tour ils ont été associés ensemble dans
la même partie
oui c'est bien oui se connaissent bien
et puis on sait que le capitaine thomas
bjorn apprécie beaucoup alexander donc
c'est un effet positif supplémentaire
qui peut nous laisser penser sans se
perdre en conjectures que si alex lévis
était juste aux portes de la sélection
il y aura un petit supplément tapas et
vraisemblablement pour autant il faut
pas se leurrer c'est une compétition
sportive de très haut niveau et le
capitaine qui a comme les joueurs envie
de gagner ne fera pas de cadeau à un
joueur plus qu'un autre
quand bien même serait-il français donc
c'est vraiment surtout conscient d'une
défaite le rabot exactement des fêtes
aux états unis donc là pour relever le
gant le sport d'une certaine manière
c'est une science exacte clair que c'est
celui qui fait les meilleurs résultats
qui a le meilleur classement et qui a
une chance de se sélectionner donc à
l'instant t très clairement alexander
est devant maintenant il ya des joueurs
français qui sont très performants en ce
moment michael lorenzo-vera gagnent
julien guerrier pareil qui était dans le
coup donc
il y a deux bons résultats chez genre
français mais celui qui a très
objectivement le plus de chances de se
sélectionner c'est alexander levy alors
parlons un peu de vous d'abord de votre
fonction
qu'est ce que c'est le directeur de
fédération alors c'est cool c'est avant
tout un travail de manager parce que
vous travaillez avec un comité directeur
et vous gérez des équipes de salariés
et puis après vous avez un métier
spécifique qui est liée à la mission
régalienne d'une fédération qui a un
lien tutelle avec l'état et le ministère
des sports et qui touche à trois
domaines la formation des différents
publics le développement de la pratique
bien sûr et l'accompagnement des
sportifs de haut niveau l'encadrement
des équipes de france donc c'est un job
assez prenants et assez passionnée elle
s'est lui facilement
christophe muniesa vous avez été vous
même proulx 1 sur le circuit c'est des
bons souvenirs
oui oui des bons souvenirs et puis le
sentiment d'avoir tenté une aventure qui
s'arrêtait en ce qui me concerne après
cinq ans de professionnalisme faute de
résultats au plus haut niveau comme je
l'espérais mais où est une aventure et
d'expériences formidable formidable le
golf est entré comment dans votre vie
assez assez tôt je suppose alors
relativement tôt mais de manière tout à
fait fortuite parce que rien ne
prédestinait non non alors mon père on
s'est mis au golf en même temps et
l'année colère mon père faisait plutôt
du motocross lui dans la forêt du côté
de pisco d'hautmont et on passait
proches de ceux du golfe il a eu envie
d'aller y faire un tour
il mit à emmener et ça est un peu le
coup de foudre avec cette activité et
j'ai assez vite en revanche décidé de me
consacrer quasiment à plein temps
évidemment à côté d'eux mais elle était
douée quoi donc
doué je sais pas en tout cas jamais ça
jamais ça j'essaie de le pratiquer
toujours de manière aussi
amicale et occasionnels que parfois
compétitive pour garder quand même le
petit frisson
j'ai gardé quelques résultats c'est
encore très très bas vous êtes encore
dans le port sous le par a donc ça
m'arrive de temps en temps c'est que
c'est quand même c'est quand même
formidable je sais pas si vous êtes
superstitieux mais si vous deviez
croiser les doigts pour quelque chose
dans les mois qui viennent ça serait
pourquoi
non mais indéniablement la sélection
d'un français en ryder cup c'est ce qui
nous fait vibrer et ce qui parfois nous
obsède mais mambo donc on est là
quelques mois de l'événement et c'est
vraiment ce qu'on appelle de nos voeux
de manière la plus chère donc on va
crier allez alexander aller alexander
merci beaucoup christophe merci à vous
glacer
[Musique]
la catalogne une des grandes
destinations du golf européen et nous
vous proposons aujourd'hui de découvrir
un magnifique réseautent le pg a
catalunya resort qui se situe à quelques
kilomètres de gijon un peu au nord de
barcelone ne parcours de 18 trous le
stadium d'abord il ya déjà accueilli
plusieurs fois l'open d'espagne et qui a
été candidat pour l'organisation de la
ryder cup
classé premier parcours en espagne et
cinquième en europe continentale c'est
un véritable joyau sur lequel il faut
assurer son swing
il ya aussi le parcours tour moins
exigeants mais si tu es aussi dans ce
magnifique environnement on en parle
avec la directrice commerciale du resort
monica martinez monica martinez bonjour
alors un mot d'abord sur le pack wii à
deux parcours le premier parcours a été
créé en quelle année 1999
le stadium cosslett championship cos et
c'est cette voie là c2c le golf le plus
réputé évidemment qui servent pour des
compétitions
vous avez déjà accueilli jusqu'à l'open
d'espagne oui on a accusé l'open
d'espagne 3 froid 2000 2009 et 2014 sur
les stingers toujours et alors il ya un
autre parcours qui a été créé un petit
peu plus tard oui c'était c'est le tour
de cause il est écrit ni demi centre
c'est un parcours un peu plus facile que
le steve young gods lequel est classé
les stallions le premier en espagne les
cinquièmes
europe continentale mais le truc c'est
aussi un parcours très joli très musée
pour les faux les amateurs de le faire
parmi les les gens qui viennent jouer
ici il est mort il est capital parce que
la catalogne est un grand pays de golfe
mais il ya aussi des gens qui viennent
de l'europe entière oui il y avait
catalan surtout barcelone et sur la sur
la provence et gérone mais on a beaucoup
de ces européens au royaume uni la
france l'allemagne la belgique et
parfois aussi des américains je disais
la catalogne c'est un grand pays de
cette région qu'est ce que qu'est-ce que
celui-là apporte de plus d'abord tu as
parcours difficile c'est un parcours
difficile
lester vion mais on allait tout le cas
les anglos facile pour les amateurs qui
joue pas assez bien mais aussi sur les
domaines on à l'hébergement on avait
restauré
on a des maisons des appartements des
activités comme le tennis mais pavel les
montants bike à l'espace donc on offrait
beaucoup d activités sur les domaines
quelle est la meilleure saison pour
venir jouer en catalogne
à mon avis prêteront et aux tendons de
mars à juin et septembre jusqu'à
novembre
oui l'été c'est très chaud les titres
ici oui tout à fait la france va
accueillir la ryder cup l'espagne l'a
déjà les déjà accueilli est ce que un
jour comme ça vous êtes tiré que le
quatrième ya réseau golf va accueillir
cette compétition
aïe on aimerait bien mais on a essayé
pour l'arrêt des caps 2022 et on a perdu
c'est la télé c'est l'italie qui va
accueillir la ryder cup 2022 et je sais
pas si on aura on aura la possibilité
d'avoir aidé le cap comme à valderrama
en 1997
mais après c'est la preuve la plus que
quand on est candidat à ce jour de
compétition c'est un très grand de golf
très intrigant parcours merci infiniment
maudit car actuelle je vous en prie et
c'était très agréable
[Musique]
alors à l'occasion de la journée
organisée par la commission j'aurais
comparé avec éric denis qui est délégué
de l'association handigolf france 2 fait
on va parler d'ajustement de dieu
handicapées et du gop
commencez par vous parce que il faut
c'est l'histoire qui veut arriver qui
est arrivé qui vous est arrivé qui peut
arriver à beaucoup de gens vous avez une
moto c'est ça donc je vais un accident
de circulation il ya 35 ans maintenant
alors moi j'avais 17 ans donc j'étais
footballeur était sportif lâcheté
sportif tu es footballeur footballeur
jusqu'à 35 ans on va dire quoi j'étais
entraîneur je suis contre 5 ans et après
on était entraîneur des résidents voilà
après et surtout après je me suis mis au
tennis donc pour pour ma société
et oui je travaille et je travaille et
oui tout à fait et après après après des
matches difficiles arrivé à un certain
âge je me suis mis au golf avec ma femme
en loisirs et là je me suis aperçu que
je pouvais jouer d'un bras en tant
qu'handicapé hélas à sa grande surprise
le golf c'est peut-être pas le truc le
plus évident le sport le plus évident
pour vous les gars mais parce qu'alors
qu'on a un peu de c'est ce qu'on croit
et risquent malheureusement c'est ce
qu'on ressent un email
fermé parce que landis est pas facile
alors c'est ce qu'on croit ma grande
surprise en fin de compte on peut jouer
avec un bras avec une jambe en moins on
peut jouer mal voyants on peut jouer en
fauteuil et donc bah le golf est
vraiment ouvert à tout le monde et tout
le monde peut jouer au golf malgré des
handicaps de la vie la vie et c'est ce
que c'est ce que montre très bien cette
journée puisque et là il ya beaucoup de
joueurs qui sont des joueurs handicapés
des golfeurs qui s'entraîne que vous
vous entraînez assez souvent tous les
deux jours alors moi j'essaie de
m'entraîner le plus possible
moi je suis en amateur intel r vous
verrez peut-être des professionnels dans
l'équipe de france
peta apporter quelque chose ou aux
handicapés
je pense que le golf pour moi c'est une
vie c'est l'ouverture sur la vie et sur
l'insertion quoi le but quand même du
golfe comme moi je le vois comme ça
c'est je le vois vraiment en insertion
de la vie parce que le golf permet
vraiment de
de se dépasser et de vivre
plein de choses ça permet vraiment
d'accepter son handicap et de passer à
autre chose que c'est à dire que de
vraiment on peut se sublimer ce se
redonner confiance c'est donc c'est une
grande grande aventure quand commence le
golf des compétitions qui sont
organisées alors nous en france on
organise maintenant un championnat
handigolf avec des open la hausse cette
année il ya 5 open de france organisés
derrière il y en avait trois eh ben on
espère que qu'on est sur une lancée
vraiment de compétition en 10 golfeurs
et tout ça pour arriver aux jeux
olympiques 2024
alors c'est pas encore une discipline
olympique le en ce moment il ya beaucoup
de négociations qui sont faites pour
pouvoir passer le golf en paralympiques
voilà donc s'il ya un gros travail qui
est en train d'être fait pour que ça
arrive
éric denis un mot sur l'association
handigolf sait combien de membres
comme nous sommes de 200 membres sur la
france et voilà c'est une association
qui date de 1993
et nous avons une vingtaine d'écoles
dans 10 golf pareil sur le territoire où
il ya même des enseignants qui sont
formés spécialement pour le pour le pôle
handi tout à fait il ya une
certification qui a été mis en place par
la fédération pour que les
professionnels puissent être adaptés aux
handicaps heures alors je voudrais qu'on
parle d'une machine qui était financé je
crois par bouygues parra golfeurs tout à
fait donc cette machine c'est un outil
de pour l'enseignement c'est un pari
golfeur qui a été financée entièrement
par bouygues construction et qui a été
offert donc à handigolf france c'est une
machine qui permet de se déplacer de
ceux de se lever
ces machines qui est complètement adapté
à leur handicap d'un paraplégique pour
aller jouer sur le parcours d'un
parcours de golf et de pouvoir jouer
dans n'importe quelle situation
je vous remercie si on est tenté
d'intéresser évidemment il ya un site
handigolf il ya le site handigolf
handigolf point fr où vous pouvez voir
et suivre tous nos envies coacher
de france mais essayer
[Musique]
oui
et vous
[Musique]
je suis avec antoine davout bonjour
bonjour patrice vous êtes l'éditeur de
magazines que tous les golfeurs connaît
ce qui s'appelle farewell et vous êtes
un formidable photographe et vous vous
faites une exposition qui swing in paris
alors vous avez imaginé évidemment en
vue de la ryder cup raid1 cup c'est
paris vous avez dit que le golf est bas
pouvait aller dans paris avec avec des
avec des photos absolument sublime alors
on va en parler de ces photos alors
exactement l'idée de base c'était donc
pour saluer la venue de la ryder cup à
paris c'était de faire un petit parcours
golfique urbain avec des jolies filles
habillées par des cons couturier
français pour son magnifique unir
l'élégance de la mode française la
beauté des des grilles mans parisien et
l'élégance du golf alors sur la première
chanteuse par la place bordeaux mais
exactement alors sur la place vendôme
elle a un bijou tout à fait singulier la
jeune fille puisque c'est la vraie ryder
cup
on a eu avec beaucoup de mal avec ça
c'est fort derrière il ya quatre
bodyguard qui surveille voilà de placer
le début de la petite promenade
parisienne golfique et urbaines ont fait
un petit peu tout faire vacciner dans
paris mais vous
[Musique]
on est là faut cordes et voix donc pas
très loin de la place vendôme
alors avec la une tenue encore d'un
grand couturier puisque c'est du
saint-laurent vintage en a qu'un voilà
donc l'idée c'était vraiment de faire
quelque chose d'un peu parisien
qui change un petit peu de tout ce qu'on
pourra voir je prends la ryder cup quand
vous avez réussi à voir d'aidé comme ça
des des images aussi pur aussi beau si
belle quoi enfin ça avec beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de patience parce
qu'il faut attendre le moment propice
alors il faut savoir qu'à paris là par
exemple cette photo a été faite vers 17
heures et pourtant il n'ya pas une
vieille mais à à paris à tous les
endroits de paris même les plus
embouteillées il y a des espaces temps
pendant 30 secondes il ya personne afin
d'éviter à ces morts donc maintenant
d'un petit bois et un long moment ça
marche pas alors la ccc le jardin
luxembourg n'est avec une
e
un modèle qui sait très bien jouer au
golf à la fait partie de l'équipe de
france minimes médical rock
d'ailleurs on voit que j'ai c'est quand
même par très léger c'est très beau l
académie
alexander levy ce qui n'est pas rien
donc voilà c'est quelqu'un qui a tout
pour elle s'appelle justin nicolas et
les magnifiques
alors voilà il ya beaucoup vous avez
fait évidemment ça ça dépend des il ya
des choses le jour et des choses la nuit
exactement pour argent évidemment
monument c'est un monument c'est un
restaurant hyper connu exactement
c'était parce que il ya des monuments il
yal architecture parisienne il ya aussi
plus que dégage la vie parisienne à
savoir la gastronomie et la lettre
d'argent on fait bien sûr partie
c'est là qu'ils subliment alors celle là
on a eu une chance incroyable
alors là on n'avait pas de problème de
circulation de voitures mais on a eu un
ciel
ainsi l incroyable je n'ai jamais vu
comme ça dans paris et on a eu la chance
de l'avoir
là on est quoi la torride où là il était
19 heures
en automne voilà et alors pour la petite
histoire l'a voulu franchir la pièce 2
évidemment dans sweeney de paris c'est
un passage obligé c'est la tour eiffel
bien évidemment paris c'est la tour
eiffel d'autant plus que certains disent
que la tour eiffel c'est ainsi inversé
bah oui il y avait même deux petits
enfants d'une tour eiffel qui avait été
fait alors la sueur grâce à aux ventes
et du vent ce jour là on a un peu lié
deux symboles à savoir la tour eiffel et
là il ya un petit côté mari dean qui
fait voler cette jolie robe qui est
signée chanel d'ailleurs et puis le
dernier clin d'oeil
voilà c'est le vélodrome national de
saint-quentin
parce que évidemment la ryder cup c'est
paris mais ça aura lieu dans le seul
territoire de 50 ans il ya quand même un
parcours de golf exceptionnelle qui est
le seul qui qui va accueillir à la fois
la ryder cup et les jeux olympiques
avant que c'est imbattable dans un
bretteur et là il ya une petite photo
vous avez ma vue national exactement qui
a été fait sur le green du 18 du golf
national
là où peut-être ce jour à la ryder cup
au mois de septembre
car si géniaux bravo un bravo ces
formulations j'appelle rien évidemment
fairway ce qui est que le magazine que
vous éditez qui paraît alors on a huit
numéros parmi numéros par an plus de
hors série les lits dévoilé plusieurs
autres séries voilà est alors en fait
l'exposition un peu le prolongement de
fer ouest où on a une approche un peu
lifestyle will golf compris sert de
vivre quoi golf c'est pas que taper dans
la balle c'est bien autre chose
la mode c'est beaucoup de choses que 19e
trophée ya plein de choses
alors ces photos on peut les voir
actuellement je pense je pense qu'on
peut aussi les acheter
ah oui il ya un site internet qui est
souligne paris ce point art d'accord
voilà option sur le site il sur le site
de fairway là l'expo est actuellement au
golf national
elle va tourner ensuite alors au mois de
septembre elle sera au buddha bar
apparaît bar et le restaurant et après
elle va bouger mais je peux pas tout
vous dire pour l'instant on regardera
sur le sur le site de far west que nous
le mettra sur notre site aussi merci
infiniment tomasi beaucoup patrie bravo
merci merci de nous avoir suivi on se
retrouve très vite pour un nouveau
numéro 2 par 78
[Musique]